- She's the original
flag girl and has been
holding it down ever
since her debut album,
"All Hail the Queen."
She went on to win Grammys,
Emmys, Golden Globes
and she was nominated for an Oscar
for her role as Mama in "Chicago."
Give it up for Queen Latifah, y'all.
(audience applauds)
Yes! Bravo, bravo.
We need to get you an EGOT at this point.
You're missing one.
- Gonna get my EGOT on.
- Yeah. I mean, EGT is still great.
So I'm not frowning at that.
So, did you hear the twins'
reaction to your song?
What did you think?
- That's so cute, oh my goodness.
Aw, man, that's cool.
I think that's cool.
- Isn't it funny?
Like a whole different
generation, like, gets to hear...
I just love them listening to songs
that I've, like, used to rollerskate to,
or like grew up with, and,
like, it's their first time.
It's crazy. If you watch all
their series, it's hilarious.
Cause it's these songs you'd
think that they'd know.
And then they're, like, so shocked by it.
It's awesome.
So wait, I actually heard
something interesting.
You're a country music fan, which I love.
So what song is like,
one of your favorites?
- "Devil Went Down to Georgia."
- What? I love that.
- Really, that was kind of a rap record,
if you think about it.
Like, it was like... that was
like a country rap record.
I was like, wait a minute.
You know, this is dope.
I heard something from Florida,
Georgia line the other day.
I don't know the name of the song,
but I was like, the pocket of
the song felt very hip hop.
- Yeah.
- But the song was very country.
- You know what I mean?
So I was like, I liked their
combination of it, you know?
And I love that country
music is now, like,
really think country music is
really leaning into so
many other genres now.
I think it's pulling
from a little hip hop.
It's pulling from a little R&B, maybe.
It's always, like, got,
like, blues under it, too.
- Yeah.
- So like, but I think it...
I like it pulling from
some of, like, the hip hop,
the track kind of, you
know, pockets, you know.
You starting to hear
some of that in the songs
that you didn't really hear before.
And I actually was going to go
to the Country Music Awards,
the last one, because I really
just, I love some of those.
I just love some of those performances.
And they're funny to me.
You know, like, I like watching usually
when Blake and Luke just
like snap on each other
for an hour or two, just
crack jokes on each other.
I'm like, that's funny, too.
But I think, yeah, I like Carrie Underwood
and anything you do is
just like, come on girl.
- Oh, you're so nice.
You don't need to
compliment me ever again.
You've made my life.
So, I love that you know me.
All right, so I saw you're
starring in a TV reboot
of "The Equalizer,"
which I love those films.
So how is that going?
- It's going.
You know, we were two
days away from shooting
and then the world shut down.
- Yeah.
- And now we are about to be shooting
in less than eight weeks, you know?
So, it just like turned
back on real quick.
So now I'm like, oh!
It's exciting because the
TV show I used to watch
when I was a kid, and then of course
we fell in love with the Denzel movies,
but now I get to create
my own version of it.
And I'm a woman as well.
So I'm a woman who gets
to kick some behind.
- Yes!
- But, you know, "The
Equalizer" is about justice.
It's about making things equal.
It's about fighting for, you know, people
who can't fight for themselves
with this amazing skill set, you know?
So, I get to like, you know,
I get to mete some justice out there,
and I'm looking forward to it.
I get to use the hands.
I'm like da da da da, you
know, get to do some shooting,
do some driving.
I'm going to go on my motorcycle, so -
- Oh my gosh, you're living
my, like, dream life.
This is awesome.
And a fact that the woman...
a fact that a woman's doing...
'cause I love the Denzel movies.
I mean, I've seen them so much,
I literally, I could recite the script.
So, but I love that a woman's doing it.
And I think that it's just a
completely different respect
of what a cool way to
like reboot it for TV.
And like you said, just a
woman, like bringing justice.
Like, I just...
ain't no woman like a
woman pissed off, y'all.
Like, so I'm so excited.
Hey, before we go, though,
I want you to tell me,
you've got a huge event tomorrow.
So, what's going on?
- Huge event tomorrow.
Doing the hashtag
#Act4Impact livestream event,
Saturday, September 26th.
It will be at 7:00 PM eastern time.
It's with the American Lung Association.
It's a live stream event to raise money
for people who have been
impacted by COVID-19,
particularly black and brown communities,
those underserved communities
who've been really hit hard.
They're going to advocate for us.
They recognized that this
was going to be a problem
way back in April,
so they started the
COVID-19 Action Initiative
to raise money, to protect people.
They want to give out masks, you know,
so people can protect themselves.
Those who don't have
them or can't get them.
They want to prevent
it, you know, obviously,
and they want to make
sure they can do research,
make sure that when the vaccines are ready
that they go to those who
really need them, you know?
There are people that have been out there
on the front lines.
And so, the black and brown communities,
we've been getting hit particularly hard
and pretty much
because of financial
issues as well, you know.
- Yeah.
- And this whole thing has
brought, like, a huge light
to the disparities
between black and white.
Well, not just black and white,
but white people and everybody else,
you know, when it comes
to the healthcare system.
So, I think this is...
So many people, especially
a lot of my white friends,
and I'm sure yours and everybody,
has been like, what can
we do, what can we do?
Well, here's one of the things you can do.
Help people out.
You know, help people who really need it.
And this event that we're having
is going to be a lot of fun.
We're going to have, you
know, some of my friends
like Jimmy Fallon, Jill Scott.
We got Common, Questlove,
Gagle, Dwayne, Keke Palmer.
We got performances.
Fitz and the Tantrums are
going to come perform,
but people are going to perform
and tell their stories
about how it's affected their families.
And we're also going to
have real doctors on there
to explain and educate so that people
really understand what's happening.
Take the politics out of it
and really just understand it
so that we can all come
together and fight this thing.
- Yeah, I know. Agreed, agreed.
I can not wait to watch it.
That's amazing.
And I can't... I'm one of those kids
that loves to learn as well.
So I can't wait to hear
all the doctors as well.
Well, okay. So, speaking
of having a good time,
I love food.
So, there's no segue for this.
So, I'm bringing this up because
I think this is hilarious.
Did you know that someone
honored you with a sandwich?
Did you know that there's a sandwich
named after you and it's awesome?
- What?
- Yes. And I'm so jealous.
I want a sandwich.
So, Sammich Restaurant in Ashland, Oregon
is serving the Queen LaBEEFa.
(they laugh)
The Queen LaBEEFa, come on.
- My assistant, Jonathan, is handing me -
- A Queen LaBEEFa, yes!
Okay, y'all it come?
I love you so much, Justin.
It comes with steak,
jalapeno cream cheese spread
and red onion on sourdough rye.
So, I'm just saying we should taste it.
It's a Queen LaBEEFa.
Cause it's just never... that's
never going to not be funny.
This is the largest sandwich
in the entire world.
- My god.
- Oh, damn. That's good.
Yeah.
- Is it good?
- Yes. It's so good.
Your Queen LaBEEFa sandwich is so good.
- Look, I'm about to spray
my Queen LaBEEFa sandwich.
- COVID friendly.
It is so good.
You've got to try it. It's so good.
Thank you so much, Sammich
Restaurant in Ashland, Oregon.
That was amazing.
All right, so be sure, y'all..
See, you like it, don't you?
It's so good. Get that little bit.
Yup.
(audience laughs)
You're so classy.
I totally talked with my mouth open.
I got to take lessons
on class from the Queen.
- It's all about this right here.
- That's me, too!
Yes, it's so good.
Yeah. I'm into that, too.
- Has that little kick, a little kick.
- I know, I like some
spice. I like some spice.
Hey, well, thank you
so much for joining us.
Everybody be sure to
watch Queen Latifah host
the #Act4Impact virtual fundraiser
for the American Lung
Association tomorrow night.
It's really important.
It'll be fun, too.
You can see it online
at facebook.com/lungusa.